how many of you guys like x-com
Final Fantasy Tactics those type of
turn-based games like kind of like a a
grid based gameplay and so I think I got
a game for you guys it's called The Lost
ilions it's developed and published by
Ocean Drive Studios and this is my
review for that game on Steam let's get
it
now let's talk about the performance of
this game this game actually performed
relatively well I will say there was
some hiccups for the game now it's not
enough to really you know dock the game
for anything I actually felt like they
did a decent job optimizing this game
for I felt like a little bit like frame
rate issues here and there uh but
besides that I think the game ran
relatively well now keep in mind like I
said I'm playing this on the steam I
know it's going to come out on the epic
game store and Xbox eventually I can't
speak for those versions I assume if it
runs like this game it's going to run
relatively smooth and that's pretty much
all I got when it turned to Performance
out you know I like to usually put the
presentation and what the game looks
like with performance and in terms of
presentation and actual Graphics I feel
like this game is a more realistic
approach to this type of style this you
know turn-based grid based gameplay that
I've really seen in most games you know
even games like x-com has like a little
bit of a cartoony style this is a very
realistic looking game and I actually
have to really give my hat off to this
company you know they did a very good
job of presentation I think all the
characters look good I think the
environments look good I think that the
actual animations look good for the most
part there wasn't nothing wrong with the
presentation of this game I for one was
getting tired of the animations on Magic
I felt like they were all the same thing
like when you actually do a spell in
this game they open up a book they read
through it and they shoot the spell and
then it will come in from the from the
sky down now I think the majority of
that was done for you know aspects on
saving money where you don't actually
show the spell being made or anything it
just comes down straight and hits now
some of the later spells is a little bit
different but for the most part they
would open up a book and it would shoot
down now it's like I said I don't think
it was a huge thing it was mainly done
for budgeting reasons I would assume but
I do feel like they could have done a
little bit differently in terms of how
these were presented to you now another
thing that I didn't really like is when
you defeat opponent an opponent in this
game they kind of like crouched to one
knee and then they and then they fall
and disappear I kind of felt like when
you're actually in the battle and you
shoot the arrow you hit them with sword
or you threw them with the spell you
know had different animations that just
crouch on one knee and then go to the
overall map and then he falls I felt
like they could have did that a little
bit better probably one of the biggest
things that annoyed me with this game
was in Los aliens There's an actual
animation where the main characters are
talking to someone on the field they'll
actually like throw their sword I
thought that was getting very annoying
every time something was like
intensified instead of having some like
epic music being played to show you that
this is a very serious situation or this
moment is a serious moment they would
like have him like throw his sword back
or or strike his sword I'm like come on
man it's kind of corny I ain't gonna lie
just a little bit it was it wasn't being
tooken seriously like imagine talking to
someone and then when you sit there and
you come across someone there you have
this altercation with them and it's an
intense moment and he's like
like I was just like could have did that
better man you know I'm not saying like
put some music on there or anything I
think I would have preferred them just
to get removed entirely because it was
it was just very corny to me and that's
not anything against the game that's
just me nitpicking it to death but
that's just how I felt about it let's
talk about the gameplay of Los aliens
like I said it's a turn-based game for
the most part if you like those Final
Fantasy Tactics XCOM style games you're
gonna like this you fight a variety of
creatures from Monsters to people what I
like about the gameplay of this is you
actually have a stronghold kind of thing
most of the time when you play these
type of games you're not really trying
to break anything down for the most part
there are certain occasions where
certain events and something like x-com
you actually have to do structure damage
but it doesn't happen a lot but what I
enjoy about this game is a lot of the
time you have to fight them on an
upscale battle where they'll be on top
of mountains or on top of you know
buildings and you actually have to use a
ram and break down the front gate now
sometimes you'll be broken up into
multiple people sometimes you won't but
what I really appreciate in this is they
make you feel that you're fighting
uphill battle the entire time keep in
mind you're supposed to be mercenaries
small groups fighting bigger opponents
and I feel like a lot of the times in
these games they make the bigger people
feel like the smaller people where a lot
of the time and Story related stuff like
this when you come across these big
units these big entities these Empires
it's always small units and you know the
story of those other games were you take
these smaller entities and you
eventually build up enough Force to
fight the bigger entities on here it
actually felt like I was fighting an
Empire it felt like they were being a
defensive structuring management
position and I actually really enjoyed
that you know where you're sitting there
going in to these towns you're fighting
them you have to Ram the gates and you
have the people up at the Top shooting
magic at you shooting archers at you it
felt like it was an actual War I think
another thing that really put a lot of
emphasis on the gameplay of this game is
how the presentation of the battles
happened it's a little bit annoying and
it's really amazing at the same time let
me explain all right so when you're
actually fighting people in the
battlefield they come up of your your
typical turn-based grid-based style
gameplay where they have their own
little space they move a certain space
they attack and Etc same thing with the
Enemy now what I like about this game
when I don't like at the same time is
you'll be on there and there'll be just
one unit well when you come across and
you actually fight them there's like an
army of going around there's a giant
Battlefield with people going swords all
out and I'm like why was that in the
actual overhaul gameplay where you know
you actually moving people around you
don't see these people fighting I think
they do that mainly it's like a
commander kind kind of thing where the
people you're moving are the commanders
in this actual war and when you actually
swing on someone you're seeing their
army that they have that they're
commanding it's not the worst thing in
the world it's not you know I felt like
it's kind of a double-edged sword where
it's really cool when you actually see
it but it kind of takes away the
immersion a little bit when you actually
Zoom back out to the actual Battlefield
that you're moving around these pieces
and you don't see all those soldiers
fighting felt like maybe if you could
have done that in the actual campaign it
would have made a little bit more sense
and not these random you know not
monsters but these random soldiers
popping up randomly when you actually
zoom in and actually do the combat
itself the UI of this game is actually
pretty well done you know it gets
straight to the point I feel like it
could be confusing there at the
beginning but once you figure out where
everything is you know it's nice to see
it done to the point where when I want
to find something it's easily found you
have your equipment tab you have the tab
with your Grim arm what a grimmar pretty
much is is just what your Mages wear you
can actually equip different Mage spells
to those grimoires depending on what
level they are there's actually a class
system in this game and I do think that
the classic is a little bit
underwhelming in terms of the amount of
diversity you can have and how you want
to play the game in those individual
characters want to play the game I don't
think it ever took to the point where I
wasn't feeling like I had like I never
had options I always felt like I had
options I just felt like they could have
gave me a little bit more variety of
gameplay with every character and not
just you know you're going to play
someone with an ax you're going to play
someone with an Archer you're going to
play someone's a mage I felt like they
could have did a little bit more in
choice on you know mixing those together
now I'm not saying they didn't do that
to a point but you know we've seen other
games do it a little bit better and
this game does do it decently I'm not
going to say it does in terms of class
system but I do feel like you know like
I said a little underwhelmed now in
terms of story you guys know I usually
save the story I don't really talk about
the story too much this story is
actually pretty good in here I'm not
going to say it's like fantastic or
anything like that I do feel like they
try to cram too much dialogue into you
there will be like when you're doing the
side stores you'll be sitting there for
three or four minutes easy just doing
dialogue and I know that that's really
good in building lore building character
development and I'm not saying don't do
that I'm just saying be a little bit
more selective when you do that I don't
want to sit here and have five six
minutes of dialogue and have these cut
scenes when I could be in there in the
gameplay that you've done very well when
I'm sitting here talking to people all
day now like I said don't not do it
Ocean Drive it's just maybe if you make
a sequel limit that a little bit I don't
want to do that man and I'm not saying
that lore and stuff and character
development's not important I'm just
saying that when I'm having all of this
time in here listening to NPCs I would
prefer being in the combat a little bit
more than that you know I feel like 35
maybe 30 70
in-game play 30 outside of gameplay
that's why I like what XCOM does XCOM
doesn't really have a lot of those style
when it comes to what you do out of
battle you know a lot of it has to do
with outside is you're building up the
Arsenal the items the research to
actually take into the battle and fight
so I feel like XCOM does this system
better than almost anyone else because
they find a good balance and I feel like
this game is a little bit too much in
the hub world man you're talking to too
many people and one thing I can honestly
say is when you actually do get into the
combat of this game game
they overwhelm you of units now sure
this is one of the games I will say you
actually have a lot of units at your
disposal that's why the class system may
be the way it is where they don't give
you a whole lot of diversity but I will
say this game has a lot
of diversity in terms of how many people
you take in there if you want to take
three archers four nights you can for
the most part you know they give you
access to a variety of different people
all the time you're constantly having
strangers join the Hub world that you
can eventually get them to join your
crew so I I give them props for that
it's just in terms of dialogue and Story
related stuff
break down a little bit on that don't
let us be in there in the hub World
talking for 20 minutes on like pointless
dialogue sometimes like finding books
I'm not for that now the question is is
lost aleons worth your money I actually
think you guys should go out there and
buy it it's on Steam currently I do
think it's coming to Xbox eventually so
if you want to wait for the console
version you know I don't blame you but I
think if you like these turn-based games
and you have a PC should go out there
and buy it man the gameplay is solid
very fun obviously like I said they
could have did a little bit more of
animations and just some of the
presentation settings in general now as
far as the presentations are very
realistic looking game and I think a lot
of you are going to enjoy that style
game because like I said you got a lot
of cartoony looking game when it comes
to this style and I'm not going to say
that stuff like xcom's cartoony but it
does got a little bit of a cartoony
looking art style to it but this is a
very realistic looking game and I think
a lot of you might actually that's never
played these style games might actually
look at this game because of the realism
in terms of art style so yeah definitely
go out there and spend all that money I
think it was a very enjoyable experience
and it's worth your money so that's my
review on the Lost aliens I actually
really enjoyed the game thank you for
the review code by the way they did give
me a review code but you guys know
doesn't matter if they give this game to
me man I'm gonna give you guys my
opinion and what my opinion in this
game's worth your money see ya